okay so I was wanting to do like math
factions run of Iron Man that starts
with believe and goes through like the
secret origin of Tony Stark and like the
introduction of Arno Stark and different
things like that but the more I thought
about it the more I realized that a lot
of that comes out of Avengers versus
X-men and then the more I thought about
Avengers vs X-Men the more I realized
that a lot of stuff comes out of
Avengers versus X-men really everything
that leads up to like Secret Wars really
comes out of Avengers vs X-Men um a lot
of the stories with characters that are
just kind of you know wrapping up or you
know Loose Ends different things like
that but even within the story of
Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers for
example the animosity between Black
Panther and uh name or the Submariner is
rooted in Avengers vs X-Men and so
because of that I was like well I mean
we could it's 12 issues we can just do
it in two videos and then just call it a
day so I figured why not do Avengers
versus X-men you know I mean it's called
Avengers versus X-Men
so uh so here's the deal really a lot of
this winds back all the way to a House
of M ego Raptor if you see this video
hopefully this helps for those of you
guys who don't know uh Egoraptor who's
part of Game Grumps had a big question
about what to read after House of M with
regards to the X-Men and Marvel did not
make it easy I mean they released like
seven different X-Men Publications it
was stupid but following the events of
House of M that story in and of itself
was just designed for the purpose of
really kind of reducing the mutant
population but what Marvel had under
their belt after that were just like a
Litany of different stories that writers
were creating and all of this led up to
Avengers and I guess Avengers versus
X-men and so there's like four main
things really with regards to the X-Men
themselves because they're the main
focus here there's like four main things
that come out of this story the first is
Cyclops the second is Charles Xavier the
third is the mutant population and the
fourth is Hope Summers so starting with
hope uh she's really kind of like the
big picture character here after House
of am the mutant population was down to
like 198 and it was really designed for
the purpose of just kind of offering
some measure of a clean slate which is
say the mutant population had grown to
be so huge and so unruly that
editor-in-chief Joe Casada was like
let's just reduce it down to an almost
minuscule number and then just kind of
start over focus on the core X-Man that
we have and then just kind of grow it
organically from there the problem is
that there were so many events going on
that Marvel never really had a chance to
sit down and let the X-Men breathe
instead we got House of M and then we
were immediately followed by Civil War
where the X-Men were just hands off and
then we were immediately followed by
secret Invasion and then dark rain and
then Siege and then fear itself and
there were just all these stories that
were going on that Marvel never really
had a chance to let the X-Men breathe
properly because they had to constantly
roll them over into these stories and so
no one could sit down and really do any
great storytelling with the X-Men
themselves but there were a handful of
stories that are important there's
really only three that are really
significant with a character of Hope
Summers the first is Masai complex the
second is uh is a messiah War and the
third is second coming and with these
three stories what they did is they
basically introduced the character of
Hope and Marvel kind of teased this idea
of well oh you know Hope Summers she
might be the next Jean Gray you know
that kind of thing but the idea was that
she would be the host of The Phoenix
Force but regardless whether she was the
host or not she was going to be the way
in which the new birth of mutants began
to crop up the problem is that never
really happened Marvel didn't do
anything with her character she just
kind of sat on the back burner for years
and years and years and years and it got
to the point that by the time Avengers
vs X-Men came around people were just
like why is Hope Summers still here now
with regards to to Cyclops his character
had become more and more extreme over
the years and the reason why was because
again coming out of House of M Charles
Xavier was gone nobody knew where he
went to you know the Scarlet Witch said
no more mutants reality returned to a
state of normalcy minus the mutant
population you know being as large as it
was and Charles Xavier had vanished and
so in his absence Cyclops and Emma Frost
took over control of the X-Men now
Professor X did come back in a story
called X-Men deadly Genesis and that
introduced like Vulcan the third
Summer's brother so on and so forth but
it introduced a lot of uh a lot of the
actions that Charles Xavier had done
that he had kept hidden over the years
and the result was that uh Cyclops and
Emma Frost more or less lost faith in
him and so they literally would not
allow him to be leader of the X-Men
instead they took over and they said you
could be you can be an advisor and
that's it and so Xavier just kind of sat
on the back burner and that was really
it and again the other part of this
being the mutant population with it
being so small the idea was to bring it
back somewhere along the line to begin
regrowing or I guess you know restoring
the median population and so with
Avengers versus X-men this really does a
lot of that especially once we get to
the end you know with regards to Charles
Xavier the Phoenix force that kind of a
thing but the crazy thing about this is
that the arrival of the Phoenix force it
really comes with the arrival of Nova of
Sam Alexander now the crazy thing about
this is I want to say there was
something called there was a Marvel
infinite comic which is basically like
their digital only series uh and it was
really just like Sam Alexander trying
just trying to outrun the Phoenix Force
as it was making its way back to Earth
in order to warn The Avengers uh really
the superhero community of what was
gonna happen and ultimately nobody could
really you know he wasn't able to make
it in time in the Phoenix more or less
just kind of makes its presence known
now with regards to like Tony Stark and
Captain America becoming aware of the
fact that the Phoenix is returning this
is huge and the reason why is because in
the eyes of them as well as virtually
anybody else who was there when Jean
Gray was the Phoenix their first thought
is whoever the host of The Phoenix force
is going to be is going to go awry now
through their own studies through their
involvement with the X-Men and so on
they know the host of The Phoenix is
going to be Hope Summers and therein
lies the Crux of Avengers vs X-Men it's
really just a battle for Hope Summers
that's making her as important as she's
ever going to be in the line of Marvel
Comics but with regards to their stance
on the Phoenix for those of you guys who
aren't really familiar with this idea in
Marvel Comics The Way It originally
played out is that Jean Gray was a
character that just no one really cared
about and the original X-Men comic she
was quite literally the quintessential
Damsel in Distress she could never you
know get through training sessions on
her own Cyclops always had to rescue her
the team always had to step in to save
her life because she'd just never do
anything worthwhile when Chris Claremont
took over the X-Men he was like that
depiction of that character sucks we're
gonna make her cool and so because of
that they introduced the Phoenix Force
Jean Gray became the Phoenix which gave
her just these god-like Powers but the
idea was the longer the Phoenix posed as
Jean Gray the more the Phoenix began to
experience emotions anger rage love all
that kind of good stuff and so because
of that the Phoenix became corrupted by
emotion and in doing so became the dark
Phoenix and so because of you know
because she was a dark Phoenix gene or I
guess the Phoenix posing as Gene
presented an incredible threat to not
just Earth but the universe as a whole
because remember the Phoenix Force
represents the sum total of all life
that has and will ever exist in the
Marvel Multiverse not just the universe
but the Multiverse there's only one
Phoenix Force throughout the Multiverse
the Phoenix force will have avatars like
the Phoenix can break itself off into
pieces and then one piece can appear in
the Ultimate Universe and one piece can
appear in the main Marvel Universe and
one piece can appear in Another Universe
and different things like that but
there's only ever one Phoenix force and
so because of this with hope being so
young and being so inexperienced the
initial concern of Captain America in
The Avengers is that if the Phoenix
takes over her she's going to become the
dark Phoenix it'll be the whole Jean
Gray Saga all over again and it's going
to lead to Absolute pandemonium now the
other half of this equation is Cyclops
himself now of course Cyclops here when
the Avengers show up and the Avengers
confront him it's really kind of a funny
scenario because on the whole it's just
the X-Men against the Avengers and
really in the initial Skirmish of all
this and once we actually get to about
the Midway point is when things start to
change but notice here you have guys
like Magneto you have guys like name or
the Submariner the reason why they're
here is because of the fact that during
the events of dark rain which was which
followed secret Invasion when Tony Stark
was kicked out as director of shield and
Norman Osborne was put in his place
Norman Osborne started implementing a
campaign of world domination or really
kind of dominating the United States and
then intending to dominate the world but
he created groups like The Dark Avengers
like the dark X-Men different things
like that which were basically
villainous versions of popular superhero
teams but the idea was that the X-Men
would not play ball with Norman Osborne
and because Norman only had control of
the continental United States they left
the continental United States and went
to an island they called Utopia and so
because of this the X-Men were joined by
name of the Submariner who is is part
mutant and rallied himself to his cause
alongside Magneto in a handful of others
who just saw Cyclops as a legitimate
leader of the X-Men and were basically
just kind of banding together because
there were so few of them left it's
really just circumstance that kind of
brought them all together but the fact
remains here that's the reason why
they're here but with the X-Men showing
up cyclops's stance is that there's only
200 of them left and hopes Summers may
be the key to returning the Avera
returning the mutant population back to
where it should be they just say you
know a whole new birth of mutants across
the world and so in Cyclops Is Mine He's
not the bad guy here and that's a crazy
thing he's the good guy fighting on
behalf of mutants who have yet to be
born who have yet to regain their powers
to have their ex genes activated or
their ex genes given to them and then
activated so of course this leads to the
most logical scenario when the Avengers
and the X-Men just start fighting one
another now in truth there's really not
a lot to be had here in terms of
discussion I mean it's kind of cool to
see you know to see these these guys
going against one another but the
ultimate goal is to get Hope Summers out
of there to get Hope Summers to a
different location so that she can be
held safe away from the prying eyes of
the Avengers themselves and the safety
of the X-Men but this is really Marvel
just kind of showcasing the different
abilities of the people who were here I
mean you know the abilities of
Spider-Man going against some of the
X-Men so on and so forth but it's also
the idea that certain people have to
choose sides namely Wolverine because
remember following the Avengers
disassembled story Wolverine was rolled
over into the new Avengers team as it
was formed by Captain America Iron Man
alongside uh Spider-Man and a handful of
others and so at this particular point
in his character's chronology because
this takes place before the death of
Wolverine he serves as both an Avenger
and an X-Man and so he's just kind of
having to pick a side now the funny
thing about this is that Marvel plays it
pretty fast and loose with his character
and has him walk both lines the closer
the Phoenix Force gets to Earth the more
in tune Hope Summers becomes with the
Phoenix forces power and so in a lot of
ways Wolverine having been in love with
Jean Gray sees very much of her in hoped
Summers especially the kind of power she
possesses the emotions she displays that
they get the better of her from time to
time and so where Hope Summers basically
just kind of incapacitates everyone
who's guarding her and races off the
other half of this is that another
Avengers team has been sent into space
in order to try to confront and stop the
Phoenix Force before it gets to earth
now again this is an impossible task the
Phoenix force is just wildly powerful
it's way too strong in fact the Phoenix
force is so powerful that Marvel has yet
to Define an actual power set for the
Phoenix the Phoenix just has the ability
to do whatever the host wants to do at
any particular point in time that's
basically the power of the Phoenix I
mean the only real description we have
was given to us in Grant Morrison's uh
new X-Men I think it was uh yeah new
X-Men where it was just like the Phoenix
just heals universes or just like fixes
problems quote unquote that's all it
does like it just does whatever it needs
to do and so it just has omniversal
power it's it's insane what it is it is
capable of and so the idea of the
Avengers trying to stop it is absolute
nonsense but at the end of the day where
Hope Summers basically Goes On The Run
Wolverine actually catches up to her and
serves the purpose of essentially
helping her achieve her goal which is to
get to the moon and then in turn access
the Phoenix Force now again the funny
thing about this is the idea that
Wolverine's kind of picking and choosing
his allegiances I mean this initially
came out of a fight between him and
Captain America you know where Captain
America is beating the absolute hell out
of Wolverine Wolverines beating the
absolute hell out of Captain America
it's kind of ironic that's a pretty
close fight because you wouldn't expect
it to be especially with you know
Wolverine's training and all these
different forms of martial arts and so
because of that it's kind of funny to
see this event unfold but when
Wolverines effectively cast out he
tracks down Hope Summers and then helps
her to get to the moon now of course
with regards to this fight against the
Phoenix it's really like this last man
standing with Thor Thor is really like
the last of the Avengers in space now
the other Avengers Aren't Dead I mean
they're very much alive it's just they
can't fight anymore because they've more
or less been incapacitated but the funny
thing about this is that it's Marvel's
showing us where the Phoenix Force
stands in relation to a lot of the
heroes that are out there because
remember for a lot of people Avengers vs
X-Men was their first exposure to the
Phoenix Force they'd never read like
Phoenix end song You Know they'd never
read any of the Jean Gray Saga under uh
Chris Claremont I mean they never read
any of that stuff they have read about
it online but they never actually read
the stories and so because of that scene
the Phoenix in full force is kind of
interesting but something that I want to
point out here is that as far as this
story goes Matt fraction and really kind
of like nerfed the phoenix like he made
it pretty weak in comparison to how it's
actually supposed to be I mean you're
talking about a multiversal force of
pure omnipotence I mean it is virtually
Unstoppable and so the kind of things
that we'll see playing out here is kind
of ironic because a person in full
capacity of the Phoenix Force which is
to say the white Phoenix of the crown
can warp reality on a universal and
multiversal scale they could just reform
anything as they wanted as they wanted
to be which kind of begs the question
where does the Phoenix reside in terms
of all the powerful entities that are
out there and that's a video for another
time we did that once before but we kind
of have to change things up since new
characters have been introduced and
different things like that but the fact
remains here that with regards to the
Avengers trying to track down Hope
Summers trying to find her location all
of them basically deduce the fact that
she's heading to the Moon you know where
Wolverine is basically helping her get
to an advanced idea mechanics tech
station and then use basically use a
shuttle in order to get them Moon once
they get there this is kind of like this
major conflict this final battle that
takes place and the crazy thing about
this is that it's like this last stand
at the Alamo it's this last attempt to
try to end the Phoenix now the other
half of this is Tony Stark himself now
once we get into Iron Man believe Matt
fractions run this is the point that
they're they're basically talking about
when it comes to uh his actions and
destroying the Phoenix this is really
kind of what the uh what what that race
I can't remember what they were called
but what that race is referring to uh
Stark basically manufactures or develops
a massive suit designed for the purpose
of effectively destroying the Phoenix
forces life entity but even then that's
why I say the Phoenix force is so
powerful because it just represents life
and so in truth in order for the Phoenix
Force to truly be destroyed you would
have to wipe out all things in existence
I mean literally just like Wipe Out the
entirety of the Multiverse with not a
single scrap of energy left because if
there's a single iota of energy that
energy will become space and then it'll
become Stars which in turn will form
planets which will grow life and the
Phoenix force will exist and so because
of that you'd literally have to wipe out
all things in existence which can't
really happen and so because of that
with the Phoenix Force finally emerging
on the moon and making its presence
known to Hope Summers the initial idea
is that if it seizes control of her
again it'll send her into a state of
chaos because she's not emotionally
ready to harness the full power of the
Phoenix not even Jean Gray was and she
was a full-grown woman now of course as
time progressed with Gene's character
she was able to kind of harness the
Phoenix but she was nowhere near as
powerful as she was during the original
Phoenix Saga it was more or less like
the Phoenix power would just manifest
occasionally but it was reduced in
Strife by quite a bit and so with Tony
Stark basically attacking this Phoenix
ultimately what it ends up doing is
instead of destroying the Phoenix force
it splits its energy into five pieces
which go into name with a Submariner
Emma Frost Cyclops Colossus and Magic
Iliana Rasputin a Colossus little sister
now why these particular five were
chosen I have been I have not been able
to find an interview that it gives any
real measure of explain Nation it's just
they were the ones who were just there I
mean it's just really done for the sake
of a sake of Storytelling but the cool
thing about this is it begs the question
of how bad are their motives are their
motives really that bad in the first
place because what we end up doing is we
actually pick up 10 days after the
Phoenix 5 are basically formed and we
travel to the island of Utopia now what
the Phoenix 5 have basically done is to
use their powers to transform Utopia
into this Utopia place now that's kind
of the irony of it is because of the
fact that with the namesake of Utopia
when it was originally formed by the
X-Men it was basically a Utopia of sorts
that was designed to be kind of like a
modern day version of genocia and what I
mean here I know we're covering a lot of
X-Men history here so bear with me but
genocia uh was basically this place that
existed for the purpose of being
Magneto's own little home away from home
uh it was Magneto's place to basically
have a location where mutants could be
free from Human oppression it was the
country that was governed by mutants
that was only for mutants now mutants
could live elsewhere in the world if
they wanted to but it was just one of
those things where you pay your money
and take your chances you live in New
York folks are gonna hate hate you
because you're a mutant if you live in
San Francisco they're going to hate you
because you're a mutant if you live in
genocia you're going to live among your
own kind now there's a whole backstory
in terms of why Magneto got genocide in
the first place and that kind of thing
but junosha itself was destroyed in the
first story arc of Grant Morrison's new
X-Men that was basically called uh es
for extinction and so because of that
genocia was just this Wasteland and so
if you read like House of M or really
any of the modern X-Men stories before
uh all new all different Marvel and you
basically go and they show you the city
of genocia that's why it's destroyed it
was just never rebuilt instead of
rebuilding it during the whole dark rain
story Marvel just introduced Utopia and
it was just like cyclops's version of
Genosha more or less it was a safe haven
for what was left of the X-Men now the
fact remains here that Charles Xavier is
effectively brought into the equation
and this is one of the most important
parts of the story and the reason why is
because of the fact that Cyclops is the
first and oldest student of Charles
Xavier not necessarily an age but he's
the oldest in terms of the people who
have been part of Charles Xavier's life
the longest he was the first student
he's the one that really shared so many
of Xavier's ideologies and that's one of
the reasons why there were some people
that loved Avengers versus X-men and
there were some that hated Avengers vs
X-Men now we'll get a little more into
that discussion once we get into the
death of Charles Xavier but the idea
here is that what psychos basically says
is your dream of a peaceful coexistence
between humans and mutants is exactly
what I'm bringing to you like you've
always wanted to see humans and mutants
existing you've always wanted to see the
world to be basically this giant Utopia
that's exactly what we're doing here now
the problem with this is that Cyclops is
doing this at the edge of a gun he's
doing this with a weapon he's basically
pointing a gun at the heads of at the
heads of everybody and saying if you
don't do what I tell you to I'm gonna
pull the trigger and so it's not really
like a Utopia so much as it is just like
an enlightened Monarch or an enlightened
dictatorship the funny thing about this
is that Hope Summers is being kept on
the island itself and hopes and I guess
you know really her kind of offering to
be here it's really more of like hey you
can be here if you want to but you can
leave anytime you want now we're gonna
find out it's actually one of those fake
scenarios where she's really not allowed
to leave but again this really just kind
of shows The Stance of cyclone because
what he does is he approaches her and
says hey look the power of the Phoenix
force is so seductive you know if I were
to offer it to you what would be your
answer and of course she says yes now of
course Cyclops Yanks away and says but
you're not ready for it and this is the
contradictory nature of his character
with absolute power or at least as they
say absolute power corrupts absolutely
that's exactly what's going on with
Cyclops right now as well as the other
Phoenix five they're being overcome by
the power they possess and it makes
sense because it's like a drug I mean
imagine imagine for example tomorrow you
woke up and realized that you could warp
reality that with enough time you could
you could train yourself to do that so
you could go to like Best Buy and you
could reach into your pocket and have as
much money as you needed at that
particular point in time or you could
just not even need money you could just
say you know what I want a big 4K TV and
you just manifest it out of thin air
imagine you had that kind of god-like
power would you be willing to give it up
would you be willing to let it go of
course not I mean if you because because
you would genuinely believe well I can
keep it contained I can keep it
controlled I can keep it from allowing
the world to run amok but you can't see
the future you don't know what's going
to happen and it may very well lead to
the to the destruction of yourself and
everything that you hold dear and that's
really what's what's kind of being
played here with regards to Cyclops is
he's losing himself and the power that
he possesses and that's why it's so
extreme that's why it's so intense is
because of the fact that Cyclops himself
was you know again the oldest student of
Charles Xavier he followed Charles
Xavier's ideologies of a peaceful
coexistence between humans and mutants
and the extreme he was the one Champion
the one guy that Xavier could always
count on to uphold his ideologies with
Cyclops falling so far so fast it's this
idea that he's almost reaching the point
that he's Beyond hope now he will reach
that place he will reach that level that
he's basically Beyond any real measure
of redemption but what we end up doing
here is we pick up with the Avengers
because again their goal is to grab Hope
Summers and their goal is to get her out
of there because the stance of Cyclops
and the other Phoenix I guess the other
members of the Phoenix five is they're
going to keep Hope Summers on Utopia
they're going to train her on how to use
her powers effectively so that when the
time comes they will imbue her with the
Phoenix force and she will become the
new Phoenix and she'll basically be a
harbinger of The Rebirth of mutants
across the Earth well again from The
Avengers standpoint it's only a matter
of time before she becomes corrupted by
that power and so what they do is they
basically initiate a Halo jump now Halo
jumps are kind of cool they seem kind of
interesting I've never served in the
military so I've never done one before
and I never would but Halo stands for
high altitude low open and what that
means is you usually jump from like 30
000 feet but the idea is to jump from an
extremely high altitude and then open at
the very moment before really before you
hit the bottom relatively speaking so
that no one knows you're there and
that's the idea to pull off here not
under normal circumstances from what I
understand where the halo jump you
usually attach flares to yourself
somewhere on your body like a foot or
hand or something like that so people
know where you are but in this instance
they're not doing that because if they
did anybody in Utopia would look up and
say hey what are those flares doing
falling from the sky and they would
realize the Avengers are coming and so
the funny thing about this is that it's
also The Avengers not really
underestimating but just taking their
chances as best they can because Emma
Frost is one of the Phoenix five she's
an Omega Level telepath she these wildly
powerful inter telepathic abilities you
know with the Phoenix Powers she can
read the minds of everyone on Earth at
the same time without being phased in
any form or fashion and so she knows the
Avengers are coming she knows they're on
their way but something that I want you
to notice here is how manipulative she's
going to become that's something I want
you to keep in the back of your head
because she's going to become a very
significant and violent character but
ultimately but Cyclops and Emma Frost
making their presents ah they
essentially just kind of show up to
confront the Avengers but then the
Avengers are met with the arrival of the
Scarlet Witch now this is basically
marveled as kind of reminding us hey
look this Scarlet Witch is still pretty
powerful but it's more so fear than it
is legitimate power the Scarlet Witch is
more powerful as herself she's more
powerful than any one member of the
Phoenix five but the Phoenix 5 are
terrified of the Scarlet Witch because
remember she's the one that said no more
mutants and stripped everybody of their
powers and so from from their
perspective she's terrifying you know
her power is Extreme and she can work
reality in such a degree that she can
just remove mutant powers from everyone
then what could she do against the
Phoenix now the important thing to keep
in mind here is that the Scarlet Witch
has been reduced in power she's not a
House of M powerful anymore that was a
moment in time that was it that was the
the absolute Peak and height of her
powers at this point she's still pretty
strong in terms of what she can do but
against the entirety of the Phoenix
Force combined into one she doesn't
stand a chance like she's just not that
powerful you know really no one is and
so what we end up doing here is of
course with a Scarlet Witch effectively
whisking Hope Summers away and allying
herself with the Avengers what this does
is it begins drawing lines in the sand
and this is Marvel effectively prepping
the second part of the story which is
when a lot of the X-Men begin to defect
away from the Phoenix 5 because of the
aggressive and the intense actions that
they begin to take towards the globe and
everybody in it as a whole okay so with
Avengers vs X-Men part two I haven't
uploaded the the first video yet I'm
kind of recording these back to back but
it's kind of crazy because I'll record
the first video the first the first
segment and then I'll just be like
people are gonna have questions about
this or they're gonna have questions
about that or something along those
lines I try to predict what you guys are
going to ask as best I can and then try
to answer them as we get to the video
but sometimes I just can't sometimes you
guys just throw like these crazy
questions you know like it's kind of
funny like I'll be on Twitter sometimes
and I'll just like tweet out to
emergency awesome and just be like hey
man like you had a really good video and
then somebody would just be like who do
you think would win in a fight and it's
just kind of funny it's just kind of
funny to me but uh but in any event the
whole idea of Avengers versus X-men one
of the major things this was designed to
do was to really kind of throw into
sharp relief how much more powerful The
Avengers were than the X-Men because
with the idea of the Phoenix 5 the
Phoenix Force really just kind of like
amplifies their powers in the extreme
and so it's really kind of a crazy
scenario because on the whole The
Avengers have always been weaker than
the X-Men but it was always designed to
be that way the Avengers were always
designed to have powers that were really
more human than anything else I mean you
did have Avengers with exotic abilities
but for the most part like Thor or like
the Incredible Hulk or really like the
most powerful Avengers whereas with the
X-Men you had characters like Vulcan who
can manipulate any form of energy you
you had characters like you know Charles
Xavier who was this wildly powerful
telepath you had people like you know
Scarlet Witch For example who was an
X-Men at one point who had the ability
to warp reality I mean you have Franklin
Richards who's a mutant that can warp
reality I mean you have all different
kinds of characters with these extreme
levels of powers and so because of that
the X-Men and the mutant population were
always designed to be stronger now I
wouldn't go as far as to say this was
Marvel just kind of being like did The
Avengers suck
I don't really think that was the case I
think it was really just kind of
designed to show us how powerful a group
of X-Men can be with the entirety of the
Phoenix Force at their disposal and so
really it's in a lot of ways it's just
kind of like these hit and run tactics
The Avengers really have no choice here
now the other half of this is the idea
that the Avengers are trying to think
about it from a technological standpoint
but the Phoenix force is Life Energy
there's really no technology behind it
the Phoenix force is not like a series
of nanites that are just like running
around and immerse themselves in flame
and take on the form of Phoenix it's not
that way it's the representation of Life
Energy there is basically dealing with
energy forces but the Avengers don't
really have very many people on their
side who can deal with that the most
powerful two beings they have at the
moment right now on the Avengers roster
is Scarlet Witch and Doctor Strange and
their power only goes so far remember
Doctor Strange's power was nerfed
already I mean you had that whole story
where you had classic Doctor Strange who
could do virtually anything but he lost
his gift from the uh the vashanti who
gave him the various Magics that he
could use he lost his connection with
them when he refused to fight alongside
them in a war in the dimensional plane
and so once he regained his powers he
only regained a fraction of the power he
used to have and so he's not nearly as
powerful as he used to be otherwise he
could just end this right now he could
just eliminate the Phoenix force and it
would just be done and that would be it
and so because of that there's a lot of
folks here you know on The Avengers side
who were dealing with it as best they
can but they're just woefully outmatched
they're just not quite capable and
that's why we end up seeing things like
Doctor Strange you know grabbing these
little items like the enchantments of
Icon that's where we have people like
black panthers saying we have to consult
Bass the panther God they're reaching
for whatever they can they're they're
just grasping at straws to try to find a
way to defeat the Phoenix 5 and it
really shows the desperation of the
Avengers where they are right now
because they really don't have a choice
they're really doing the best they can
with what they have and that's really
about it now in terms of the
manipulative nature of Emma Frost this
really comes to fruition with regards to
name one of the Submariner now the
implication here is that the two of them
are having an affair that the two of
them are basically sleeping together now
this is really just kind of given to us
through the fact that they share a kiss
that kind of thing but Emma Frost also
says look Neil I know where they took
one of our own I know where they took
transonic a member of our group and
she's being kept in wakanda now the
reason why this is Emma Frost being so
manipulative is because of the fact that
she's basically going to lead to
Neymar's destruction or really not death
per se but him losing his his portion of
the Phoenix Force but Emma Frost has
always been this way Emma Frost has
always been manipulative going all the
way back to like you know really even
before Graham Morrison's time on new
X-Men really during Grant Morrison's
timing and Chuck Dixon's time my new
X-Men when Jean Gray walked in on a
psychic Affair between Cyclops and Emma
which kind of led to Jean Gray basically
being forced out of the picture and Emma
Frost and cyclops pairing up the fact
remains here that Emma's always been
that way now for a lot of especially
women readers that was a refreshing
thing because they looked at her as like
an empowered chick right like she does
whatever she needs to do in order to
achieve her goal but the downside of
this was that it made her look very
vindictive and it made her look very
Petty and so it really kind of took away
from her accomplishments because of the
road she took to get there but the fact
remains that with regards to the whole
you know tension between Black Panther
and name of the Submariner this comes by
way of the fact that Neymar attacks
wakanda now it's not as though he just
does this blindly I mean he does to a
degree but Emma Frost was preying on the
desire of Namor to engage in conflict
and engage in war name was always been a
very heavy-handed character when it came
to like dealing with enemies in terms of
you know Marvel Comics uh if somebody
just strayed across Atlantis or even if
they accidentally harmed somebody from
Atlantis name of the Submariner was like
film in prison and kill him and that was
it that's just the way it was I mean
there were no if ands or buts you know
you harm somebody from Atlantis and you
were done with all your living according
to the name where the Submariner this is
an extension of that belief system with
an almost infinite amount of power and
so with the kind of ability that he
possesses he looks at Cyclops as a
failure in a lot of ways because what
namour says is This Is War if you're not
with us you're against us and if you're
against us you're in the way you chose
your side and you knew what was coming
sorry about your luck that's really just
kind of the stance that he takes and so
him attacking wakanda is the most
natural progression of his character now
the other half of this brings into the
idea Kun loon now really mad for Action
is just kind of like bringing some of
the stuff that he did with regards to
Iron Fist into the equation which is one
of the reasons why we covered the Run of
Iron Fist but there was a point in the
history of Kun loon when one of the Iron
Fists long before Danny Rand had
basically faced uh faced against and
staved off somebody who basically became
a host for the Phoenix Force now there
isn't a whole lot of expansion given
there it's basically just saying this is
one of the things that one of the many
Iron Fists throughout the history of the
Iron Fist mantle have done just one of
the multitude of things that they've
achieved but what it does is it brings
[ __ ] loon in because it means they have
experience with the Phoenix none of them
have become a phoenix entity but they
have experience with it on how to train
their uh their iron fists to cope with
the Phoenix Force now at the end of the
day Dany ran the Iron Fist going against
any one of the Phoenix five is like
throwing a rock at a train I mean it's
not gonna do anything I mean it's it's
comedic at best and all they can really
do is just buy time and even then it's
seconds maybe I mean he just doesn't
stand a chance the Iron Fist is just
nowhere near powerful enough but what
this does do is it grants a reprieve for
Hope Summers will reign and a handful of
others to basically Retreat and then use
kunloon as a base of operations because
remember [ __ ] loon is in another
dimension so you literally have to cross
a dimensional barrier to get to kunler
it's like that phrase from uh from
Pirates of the Caribbean it's a place
that cannot be found except by those who
already know where it is but the fact
remains here that with regards to
wakanda the name of the submariner's
actions here just lay waste to the city
I mean he basically musters all of his
forces and just brings them to Bear onto
wakanda and just eradicates the entirety
of the city killing tons of people in
the process now this creates a blood a
blood Vendetta between Black Panther and
name of the Submariner and so when we
get to Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers and we start referencing things
like why it is a black panther hates a
name of the Submariner so much we will
point back to this story so you guys can
see what it is that we're talking about
now with regards to name of the
Submariner effectively being defeated he
loses his portion of the Phoenix Force
but what we end up finding out here is
that when one member of the Phoenix 5
loses their their connection to the
Phoenix Force the remainder of the
Phoenix Force so I guess that portion
spreads throughout the remainder of
those individuals who were bonded to the
Phoenix and so because of this what it
does is it sets the seeds for a civil
war between the remainder of the Phoenix
five really the Phoenix four now because
they're all imbued with name of the
submariner's power and so the idea in
all of their minds of the idea in the
mind of Cyclops and the mind of Emma
Frost the mind of Colossus the mind of
Ileana Rasputin is if everybody else
dies or everybody else loses their
connection they'll be basically maintain
the totality of the Phoenix force and so
what it does is just kind of make this
race to bring all the others down and so
because of this we end up picking up
like eight days after the you know
basically the fall of name of the
Submariner and what we end up finding
out here is that using [ __ ] loon as a
base of operations The Avengers are
launching these attacks to basically go
into the main Marvel Universe grab what
other members of The Avengers they can
and bring them back and so really the
Phoenix five are really the I guess the
Phoenix 4 at this point have just kind
of taken over the earth I mean there's
really no way for the Avengers to stand
on their own now in the background of
all this Hope Summers is basically being
trained in a lot of the you know various
forms of mysticism and martial arts
available to [ __ ] loon now the funny
thing about this is that like Kung Fu is
not going to do her any good but the
idea of her being trained in kung fu
isn't about like kicks and punches and
self-defense it's about her honing her
soul coming to grips with who she is
what she's about and getting a better
understanding of herself and so because
of that it makes her more in tune with
her own powers gives her kind of like a
spiritual piece which in turn will give
her better access and a better
understanding of her own powers and make
her more formidable because in the end
it all really comes down to her I mean
right now the Avengers are in shambles I
mean weather is Captain Britain which he
never really mattered like Scarlet Witch
Ant-Man Red Hulk She-Hulk Wolverine I
mean they're all basically just being
completely crushed with regards to you
know Tony Stark everybody's doing all
the research they can but in the end it
doesn't matter it doesn't make a
difference they're all basically being
taken down and so what we end up doing
is joining The Avengers you know is they
basically make this you know another
campaign into the main Marvel Universe
but we end up finding that Ileana
Rasputin uses her powers to basically
command the forces of limbo and
essentially brings in Hell on Earth now
in the realm of Marvel Comics limbo is
one of a multitude of Dimensions that
are basically hell I mean you have a lot
of those like you actually have the the
dimension of Hell which is where
Mephisto hangs out at him Mephisto is
basically the devil in Marvel Comics but
there's a lot of Dimensions that are
filled with like fire and brimstone and
demons and monsters and different things
like that but limbo is a dimension that
Ileana Rasputin has total control of and
calls her own she's basically queen of
that realm and so because of that when
she brings it over to Earth most of the
Avengers were able to get out in time
but Spider-Man is really kind of like
the last man left you know offering what
little Solace he can offering what
little safety he can while the Avengers
rescue those who have been taken by the
rest of the Phoenix four and so what is
up happening is Spider-Man Actually
manipulates the two of them and this is
one of the coolest things here because
in the renew year of our story from
Secret Wars one of the things that
Marvel established is that Spider-Man
tells jokes for the purpose of throwing
off his enemies whereas enemies are
taking the situation seriously when it
seems like Spider-Man's not taking them
seriously it throws them off it keeps
them off guard knocks them off bounds
because they don't know what to expect
it's like the classic Bruce Lee method
of fighting right I mean you know don't
clinch your fist until the moment of
impact dance around always be on the
Move Spider-Man is much the same way in
terms of how he conducts himself but the
way he does this is he preys on his
knowledge of the defeat of name of the
Submariner and begins talking to Ileana
Rasputin and Colossus you know basically
saying you guys are brother and sister
do you guys really want to fight each
other I mean why would you want to find
each other because if one of you Falls
the other will get you know that
person's power and so what he does is he
basically plants this little thought in
their brains that if Colossus takes out
magic or if magic takes out Colossus
they'll gain the other's power and so at
this point it's really just kind of
feeding on their bloodlets feeding on
their on their corruption and just kind
of going from there just letting nature
take its course and so things unfold
exactly as we would expect it to when
Ileana Rasputin and Colossus end up
fighting one another and It ultimately
results in both of them being defeated
and the remainder of their power
spreading to Emma Frost and cyclops and
so because of this you know Cyclops
effectively locates [ __ ] loon breaks
into it with the intention of grabbing
Hope Summers and bringing her back and
so because of the stance that people
like Emma Frost are taking where she's
basically forcing mutants that are in
Utopia in a subservience because Cyclops
is becoming so extreme and willing to
kill anyone who gets in his way
ultimately Magneto begins to see himself
and the two of them and that's what's so
ironic here about this one of the
reasons why Magneto's character was so
cool during Avengers vs X-Men is because
how we see Cyclops and Emma depicted
here this is 1990s Magneto hell this is
this is 1980s 1970s Magneto the guy who
will do whatever it takes in order to
keep mutants safe even if it means
crushing and conquering the world and so
because of this Magneto does the only
thing he can do he basically walks out
into the open and contacts Charles
Xavier and says we need your help on
this now Xavier was well aware of what
was going on up to this point but he had
always kind of been hands off he had
always sort of stayed away from
everything that was going on simply
because of the fact that in his mind
there had to be a peaceful way to bring
cyclops back and he was really just kind
of biting his time and waiting for that
moment to talk Cyclops down and bring
him back to his normal self before he
was too far corrupted from the Phoenix's
power but at the end of the day we also
get a better understanding of Hope
Summers powers in the sense that Hope
Summers can basically duplicate the
powers of others that whenever she's in
a close proximity of her of a person she
can copy their abilities now the cool
thing about this is that she can do it
with more than one so she's like Peter
Petrelli from Hero season one before
they nerfed his character and screwed
him up and so because of that she's been
basically a character who's just a
living copycat of anybody else's powers
which makes her wildly powerful because
imagine that she was standing in close
proximity to Emma Frost and Colossus
Scarlet Witch or something like that
she'd have all three of their powers she
could use Emma Frost telepathy she could
use Scarlet Witch's reality warping
powers and she would have the organic
metal skin of Colossus it's kind of
crazy what it is that she can do and so
what we end up doing is we basically
jump back over to Captain America and
this is really the Avengers in their
most desperate hour because what we do
is we join Captain America out in the
middle of nowhere and Captain America is
just beseeching some unknown person
simply saying look we've exhausted every
option we need every ounce of help that
we can get I would not come here unless
it was absolutely necessary but I
absolutely need your help will you help
me you have to have been seeing what was
going on with the Avengers and the X-Men
will you help me with this conflict and
we ultimately end up finding out the
person that Captain America is talking
to is the Incredible Hulk now this is so
cool and the reason why is because of
the fact that after
um after Greg Pack's run we ended up
getting the Incredible Hulk by Jason
Aaron but basically he just went into
like a period of self-imposed Exile he
just disappeared off the face of the
planet for however long he just stayed
hidden from everybody and so with the
Incredible Hulk being brought in here
this brings in a massive Powerhouse at
the same time we also end up joining or
traveling to Wisconsin and joining Rogue
and Rogue basically joins The Avengers
and what we end up finding out here is
that Charles Xavier has effectively been
going alongside the Avengers and
mustering all these forces that are
Avengers and X-Men related and so what
this is designed to do is to show us
that people have basically walked away
from Cyclops and Emma Frost they've lost
faith in them they've lost faith in
their mission and that's really where it
is that Cyclops and like Magneto began
to stray that's where they really began
to kind of part ways it's because
historically speaking Magneto was always
mutants first if there's any group that
can count on me to to ensure their
safety it will always be mutants
everybody else is second best side
Cyclops initially presented himself this
way and that's why so many mutants
rallied to his cause is because he
showed up and said look we're going to
turn this mutant island of Utopia we're
going to turn it into a refuge for
mutants but then ended up going you know
from being this enlightened dictatorship
turning into this totalitarian
power-hungry regime and that's when
mutants began to walk away especially
those individuals who were looking at
the at the Avengers and saying look we
fought as friends once we'd like to
fight his friends again because Cyclops
and Emma Frost are beyond the point of
control and so because of this we end up
joining Xavier kind of entering into
cyclops's mind and this is cool because
it's a battle being fought on two fronts
on one side it is Xavier in the mind of
Cyclops more or less kind of talking to
him offering some measure of distraction
on the outside it is all the Avengers in
these X-Men facing off against Cyclops
so it was really kind of cool because
it's just like Cyclops versus everyone
and it's it's amazing to see because at
the end of the day Emma Frost and
cyclops are the last two standing and
try as they might The Avengers just
don't have the power to take both these
guys out on their own because they're
just so strong they're just so capable
and so because of this you know in this
moment of desperation in this hour of
basically realizing he needs more power
Cyclops turns against Emma Frost and in
doing so basically incapacitates her and
steals her portion of the Phoenix Force
which basically transforms him into dark
Phoenix now again this is the crazy
thing here is because this shows us how
far Cyclops has fallen and this was
designed for the purpose of ushering and
cyclops into a new era of taking Cyclops
in a new direction to where he would be
more extreme he would become like the
classic Magneto but in a more extreme
capacity so for those of you guys who
are reading the stories or online
reading different articles about how
Cyclops has basically quote unquote gone
evil this is the story that set the
stage for that but the First Act he does
with the totality of the Phoenix Force's
Powers is kill Charles Xavier and this
was really like him crossing a line that
he can't come back from now the other
half of this is that in some ways it is
Marvel get giving Cyclops an out is
basically Marvel saying this is what
happens when a person becomes fully
imbued with the power of the Phoenix
Force they don't know how to control it
they fall down the path of Darkness
because it's so much power that they
almost go completely insane and in some
cases when they become the dark Phoenix
they do lose their minds in their
entirety and so this is really just like
a last-ditch effort by everyone to try
to Stave off and try to end the power of
Cyclops once and for all and so what
ends up happening here is Hope Summers
and Scarlet Witch effectively team up to
bring cyclops down now the cool thing
about this is that it's also this idea
that Cyclops recognizes how far it is
that he's falling and it's really him
just kind of recollecting on his own
memories you know going back and looking
at the times that he and Wolverine
fought together looking at the times
that he was a student of Xavier the
death of Jean Gray you know these are
moments that he looks back on and he
begins to realize that he's effectively
losing himself but the problem is that
what's happening to Cyclops now is
exactly what happened to Jean Gray
corrupted by power not able to control
it the Phoenix Force takes on a life of
its own and so using a moment of
distraction Pope Summers just kind of
immerses you know through this fire
looking like Jean Gray but in this brief
second she takes the moment alongside uh
alongside Scarlet Witch to basically
take out Cyclops to beat him and then
absorb the entirety of the Phoenix now
the implication seems to be here that
the Phoenix was always trying to find
its way back to Hope Summers and it was
just kind of doing so and so it seems
like there was some measure of personal
control by Cyclops over the Phoenix that
he basically wouldn't let the Phoenix
leave that seems to kind of be What's
Happening Here the problem is that with
this end of the story it just wraps up
just like that it wraps up so fast and
there's really not much in the way of a
great ending here because it's just
really kind of like well where do we go
from here and what ends up happening is
Hope Summers having been perfectly in
tune with the Phoenix Force becomes the
white Phoenix of the crown the problem
with this and the reason why it doesn't
make any sense is because Jean Gray was
always billed to be the perfect host for
the Phoenix which is why she became the
white Phoenix of the crowd she and the
Phoenix Force were effectively one in
the same she was born to be a host for
the Phoenix when she basically died
quote unquote and joined the Phoenix
force and became the white Phoenix of
the crown she was going to be the one
singular being that basically fixes
what's broken in the universe whatever
that happens to me whatever Marvel wants
it to mean at any particular point in
time with Hope Summers becoming the
white Phoenix of the crown and Jean Gray
nowhere in sight the question has to be
asked what happened to Gene but before
we even get an answer to that question
before we ever find out what happens
Scarlet Witch more or less just kind of
approaches Hope Summers and says no you
are never really meant to have the
Phoenix force and she simply says no
more Phoenix and the Phoenix force is
destroyed and that's it and so it's a
very anti-climactic and lackluster
ending to what was otherwise an insanely
great story but what comes out of the
death of the Phoenix Force more or less
is basically this emergence of mutants
all over the world mutant Powers began
cropping up and popping back up all over
again so once the story really begins to
wind down once it all basically begins
to come to a close uh psycho is
effectively taking taken prisoner by The
Avengers because of the fact that he had
killed Charles Xavier you know he's
taken prisoner he's basically held in
stasis but it sets the stage for him to
effectively break out and then
eventually go on to you know lead his
own group of X-Men or you know more of
like a rogue group and so on and then of
course Hope Summers just kind of takes
off into the sky to find her own place
but again it's it's not the best ending
I was really disappointed in the endings
of the story because I kind of felt like
Marvel wrote themselves into a hole and
didn't know how to get out but in any
event uh if you guys are new here to
Comics explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the Rob
cork if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you guys later
peace
[Music]
[Applause]